à la différence de l'animal l'homme lui
est humain et c'est ce caractère
d'humanité que nous allons explorer
aujourd'hui autour d'un spécimen
d'humanoïdes particulier l'homme du 20e
siècle
comme vous pouvez le constater l'homme
du xxème siècle n'est ni plus ni moins
beau que celui des siècles précédents
ainsi notre ami coco puisqu'il s'appelle
coco dit bonjour coco bonjour coco non
bonjour bonjour
notre ami coco donc et sans doute moins
bon que romeo mais plus beaux nettement
que quasimodo voyage intérêts non
l'ensemble la morphologie générale est
la même qu'avant à ceci près cependant
pour xxème siècle certains hommes comme
du reste notre ami concours portent des
semelles orthopédiques ce que l'on ne
voyait jamais aux ménages par exemple
c'est grâce à ça que j'ai pas fait mon
service
de même la forme du crâne n'a pas
beaucoup changé au cours des siècles des
mois et même des années
elle est toujours ovoïde ob longues
robes du soir et il peut mettre la main
j'ai pas les cheveux gras le front est
toujours placé en haut du visage au
dessus du nez à la base du cuir chevelu
le nez toujours au milieu de la face
même si les tordus comme c'est le cas
ici
tordu toi même et la bouche toujours en
bas au dessus des coûts et oui les
filles c'est pas demain que servir une
modèle et picasso en fait ce qui
caractérise réellement sur le plan
physique l'homme du 20e siècle
c'est le port de la barbe vous veillez à
laisser une vraie la barbe à notre
époque en effet présente deux avantages
d'abord elle permet de se dissimuler
quand on a commis une villa d'action je
vous jure c'est pour moi et elle est un
véritable garde-manger
alors quand on a un petit creux à 4
heures je dois bien avoir du jaune
d'oeuf de midi à mettre sous la dent
en ce qui concerne le niveau
intellectuel de l'homme du 20e siècle
aucun doute celui ci est beaucoup plus
malin contre x beaucoup plus apte à
défendre ses propres intérêts mieux
armés pour affronter la vie c'est pour
moi qu aurait construit une cathédrale
avec un salaire en dessous du smic
un jour de congé par semaine et pas de
vacances au mois d'aout dès qu'il se
sent interpellé par une question d'ordre
international l'homme du xxème siècle se
montre très inventif j'ai buté deux
vieux j'ai pété les lunettes à 2 minutes
dans les files d'attentes
j'ai foutu dit à la chaîne affirme je
suis passé devant tout le monde est
totale je les aimais place pour
barcelone munich au parc des princes la
culture est une des préoccupations
majeures de l'homme du 20e siècle
je regarde le grand échiquier tous les
mois depuis 10 ans j'ai toujours tout
bon jeu des mille francs je paye toutes
mes mensualités pour être abonné pour
recevoir mise en cycle [ __ ] universel et
en plus j'ai un abonnement historia
alors qu'on vienne pas m'emmerder en
disant que je suis pour un homme
responsable en ce qui concerne le sexe
c'est à une véritable émancipation
une libération totale de l'individu et
de sa fonction de ses pulsions les plus
hautes que nous assistons en cette fin
deux 20e siècle bon ma feignasses de
femmes est en train de faire la
vaisselle
je vais aller aux [ __ ] c'est ça c'est
samedi j'ai touché la paye
sur le plan politique dans certains pays
comme le nôtre le 20e siècle a permis à
l'homme de choisir librement le
gouvernement qu'il désirait et ce dans
le strict respect de la liberté d'autrui
premièrement je fais pas de politique
deuxièmement mes opinions politiques ça
regarde que moi
troisièmement ce qui est pas d'accord
avec moi je lui casse la tête 4e manche
dit jamais pour qui je veux avant et
après je dis que j'ai voté pour sika
gonier cinquièmement ce mois-ci ya la
guerre je m'en fous à mon âge seraient
plus mobilisés et encore d'occupation
faut pas dramatiser sur na de
l'éducation peut très bien s'en tirer
mais si révolutionnaire que soit vous
êtes de voir les moeurs de l'homme
moderne
nous remarquerons qu'il reste toujours
attaché à l'une des valeurs
fondamentales de notre civilisation
la cellule familiale bon maman mais à
son club de majorettes
ma femme est à l' usine mes vieux sont l
hospice avec d'autres vieux donc ils
s'ennuient pas eh ben je suis peinard je
vous quitte je vais boire un coup au
bistrot